yeah that corporate guy oh yes do you
need me negative Omega the world mini GD
Lassonde before this trip to a remote
part of northeast India there were six
thousand nine hundred nine living
languages known to scientists now there
is one more mark Kippy
national Geographics enduring voices
project brought linguists Gregory
Anderson and David Harrison to a region
of India that requires a special permit
just to enter to reach one village where
this language is spoken the expedition
team had to cross a mountain river by
bamboo raft it would be the first known
time the language would be recorded
arunachal pradesh is the home of an
endangered language known as Koro
it's part of the tibeto-burman language
family a group of some 400 languages
what's illegal farewelling it but until
now
four-oh was unknown to world linguists
only about 800 people are believed to
speak it with few underage 20-person
anderson an indian linguist ganesh
mermoo sat in the homes of the speakers
making recordings as people shared
vocabularies and stories in Koro the
researchers were in the region to study
- poorly known languages but in speaking
to the locals detected the third
surprise language it contains very
sophisticated knowledge that these
people possess about this valley the
ecosystems the animals the plants how
they survived here how they adapted so
if they switch over to another language
a lot of that knowledge will simply be
lost
the scientists believe Goro may have
sprung from slaves in the region but
they say more research is needed to
determine precise origins linguists
consider half the world's nearly 7,000
languages endangered threatened by
cultural changes ethnic shame and even
government repression but at least with
the enduring voices project languages
like Goro can be recorded and documented
for the ages novalee
[Music]
you